[Music]
all right it's time for america's
favorite show it's time for hot seat
let's see hot seat the show with the
hottest seat and the hottest questions
for the hottest guests
we started off cold and then we turn up
the heat that's it and today we got alex
on the show on the hot seat hey hey
yo
it's the first time he's the first time
on hottie it's crazy we've been doing
hussy for so long it's crazy hasn't been
a hot seat yeah first of all first time
all right all right alex let's start it
off cold oh you got a question for him
oh always dude but but you please if you
have a question i got a question let's
start off cold
um
how would you simply explain who you are
to the audience that don't know who the
[ __ ] you are
who i am uh i'm like what kind of things
do you do and what do you have value
yeah what do you what yeah what what do
you thinks what kind of things man do i
do like like if they'll be like oh this
guy's like a boxer this guy's like a
stand-up comedian like people want to
know what are your skills dude yeah like
people that are skillets don't come here
like before people look at you and go
what a waste of space you're like no no
i have value here's my phone
because every time somebody sits here
you got to be somebody or be something
you know you can't just like sit here
you also take up a lot of space yeah
you're a big boy i fit in this chair
actually hey yo yeah they look proper
feels like it might break but look like
a king of that please be careful answer
the question though uh um what do i do i
play video games hell hey professional
gamer i work out
bodybuilder no power lifter power lifter
how much you squat dude uh my highest
squat was 601 pounds that's not very
much
not even a ton
yeah dude oh [ __ ] my bench was 463
oh [ __ ] so if you add it together that's
a ton
if you add it together that's already a
ton 622 just throwing that out there but
dude how come you had such drop off from
like where you're squatting to like
where you're where you're dead lifting
that's crazy because my arms are short
so
my mechanics you know they don't really
work out i'm playing my favor for
deadlifts so but it helps with the bench
my bench wanted me like every single one
of my meets so
can't complain you came in first yeah
what does it feel like to come in first
like a lot of people in the room don't
know what that feels like yeah i don't
know how it feels not to come in first
but like
you know it feels good
sick
your first place out of powerlifting me
mm-hmm at a lot i think 14 out of 15.
holy [ __ ]
in your weight class what's your weight
class
uh i competed in the 220's and then the
242's so he's an athlete athlete all
right and uh and a gamer and a gamer and
i like to take pictures and take videos
a video our podcast our mma podcast so
you got only fans
i wish i should start one you're you're
a podcaster
what kind of things do you guys podcast
about tell them alex this is your hot
seat we talk about mma so it's called we
out here mma so we go over all mma news
new fights did you and this gentleman i
mean this gentleman and our friend
gilbert uh so
yeah
pretty much it that's all i do what
games do you play uh call of duty call
of duty basically i was playing valor in
apex legends we had talked about it i
downloaded that pirate game too but
again so i'm gonna play let's play oh
okay we didn't get we can swap members
last time so we'll play parking
but yeah call of duty mainly and then uh
apex legends but
if you're such a gamer how can we even
play games with us because i don't want
to show you all up oh
not to make it about me but um yeah ryan
ryan kicked my [ __ ] ass at the games
and i'm yeah you're kicking the shot at
me though i kicked the shirt at you but
i was expecting that but
you can't show me a shotgun he killed me
like eight times in a row and he wasn't
even button-mashing his deliberate
movements he knows
he was playing my character and he
kicked my ass with his character but he
thought he was controlling my character
the whole dude i just got wrecked in
cowboy game too i died like the whole
time
sunset [ __ ] showdown man he was
wrecking my ass big time dude holy [ __ ]
anyway you're you're waving cowboy gamer
probably not huh no i honestly i knew a
couple of those games on there but i
didn't know a lot of
i don't know i don't know generation
yeah i don't have well like my cousins
had those systems like we never really
had them so like how old were you four
right how old am i yeah 28
how old were you back then when your
cousins had it
like maybe each
seven or something like that that's why
we [ __ ] remember those are [ __ ]
boomer games
those are boomer games playstation two
okay there we go wow you did some sick
graphics with spoiled ass brad played a
lot of tekken
uh a lot of tekken bloody roar
uh gran turismo that's what separates
our generation because i think ours was
first nintendo
we were in the 2d world yeah we were
twisted metal black though oh it's
twisted dude game [ __ ]
dude the stories were [ __ ] up as hell
and they kept me up all night and i was
scared shitless isn't that the crazy
clown car thing yeah nick would hate
that huh the stories were real [ __ ] up
too yeah had that ice cream truck if you
were in like the metaverse and you had
to like choose a game avatar to
represent you who would you choose
mega man
mega man is cool
uh not a first choice though yeah no no
definitely i totally forgot about it
like a mega boy the heat mega boy i
think there is a mix that was the
equivalent of you walking up to his he's
like a merchant and you're coming up and
you're like what do you think of this
you're like yeah that's cool
i forgot about mega man everyone i don't
know
if i could be any you'd be a gorilla i'd
be a girl
that's your pp yeah that's my guy right
your profile pic
on a mario kart or the old school one
where like he's trying to throw
i like those games too but i do like
mario kart
i used to play a lot when when we had a
wii system the mario kart yeah
undefeated with luigi and the mock bike
browser's castle three i will [ __ ] you
up at mario kart the loser has to suck
the other guy's dick all right all right
dude
he's got a baby
i will bring mario kart justice
oh wait please oh please don't please
don't
like wait maine doesn't have mario kart
awesome
how'd you get a mario kart machine here
oh did you guys want to get one yeah it
was expensive those are really expensive
man with the chairs right and the
[ __ ] wheel so we got a samurai suit
instead
oh what the [ __ ]
the one you can't even play with the
samurai suit i mean i guess you can just
play it though you can just buy the
separate components and then just have
all driving games including mario kart i
didn't even think of that same that's
what people do they just buy the chair
the wheel this guy's progressive this
guy knows what he's doing
he's got the weed though too but he's
not in the hot seat okay sir so
what uh what's something what's
something about powerlifting that a lot
of people don't understand or that maybe
people don't respect about the sport
that they don't respect about this yeah
give me an angle everyone disrespects
powerlifting we know that
yeah
honestly i was like a power lifter that
just like did i wasn't like too involved
in the sport in the sense he's like i
don't give a [ __ ] about my first place
but you just keep winning yeah basically
but no it was just like
i think what people don't respect is
like how how much work it takes
especially people that do take steroids
and stuff people see that and they're
just like oh he's on steroids
but the amount of work that you have to
do to like prep for a meal like even if
you take steroids you still gotta work
out a lot of work that you have to do
especially if you're on steroids your
work rate goes up by a lot so you're
still it's not like you're
barely doing anything you're getting
stronger so those are the real heroes
they're grinding exactly you stop the
grind it's a lot in your body it's
taxing
is it really worth it
kind of not really once you get to like
a certain point because no one's getting
paid or anything like that unless you're
like a top top athlete that's like
sponsored uh but yeah i think that's
probably the most
the biggest thing that people do what
got you into power lifting
um i moved here from arizona and i was a
little out of shape
and then the guys that owned the gym
that i was working out at were
powerlifting at the time so you didn't
even know anything about it and you just
like that's the first place you started
working out at yeah and then you just
kind of got into it that way and i was
naturally strong so like within i think
three months that's my problem too yeah
yeah three months i was already
mentioning 300 pounds and i was already
squatting in three months of starting a
workout uh no not working out i had
worked out before oh
but never like powerlifted and then when
we started powerlifting i got like on my
first little program in like three
months and i already benched uh 315 so
they were like oh [ __ ] okay you should
keep doing this so i'm just kept doing
it and veggies is like you know just for
people don't know you just do it you
gotta do it once right
yeah at the meet it's like you take it
out you didn't know that they said start
bring it down you have to pause it until
they say press and then you press it
whoa then you have to wait till they say
rack it and then you rack it you don't
do like five times no just one so you
get three attempts so like you would
start with like a lighter attempt just
to lock yourself in the meat and then
your next two would be you know probably
like uh a current like your current
personal best or like maybe a little bit
above that and the third attempt you
should kind of go all out just to try
and get like a new number for yourself
what do you think of bart's numbers and
why do you think he's way worse than you
yeah
question i've been waiting to hear you
know bart grinds and he does a lot of
work so i think you know what no no why
not here like you could just say freely
you know i give my theory yeah i think
that he works out too much and his
muscles actually are weaker because of
it i agree i see it when i do when i
watch him survivor and solo anecdotal
[ __ ] but when i'm watching survivor
it's always the most yoked dudes getting
absolutely wrecked on the challenge
because he's too tired in the practice
yeah cause they're all they're all
yolked out and their muscles all burning
already like all day and then you know
they go to the challenge they get
[ __ ] absolutely wrecked yeah no i
think bart's pretty strong i've competed
with bart a bunch of times same weight
class how can we not save weight class
but that's the thing too he's also a
weight class below me but talk some sure
he's i'm pretty sure he's one so i don't
think he's one of anything when his
bench comes nowhere near mine but i'm
sure he's still one
yeah karate thing by default or jiu
jitsu something like that he like
absolutely won because he showed up yeah
nobody else showed up so he won
something that's the only thing bart's
ever wanted yeah we were there we were
there really embarrassing yeah today's
video is brought to you by curology
i love curology you know why why because
my face is always confused
my face like my actual face skin right
yeah is greasy as [ __ ] all the time yeah
and my lips are always dry how do you
have why don't you just go like this and
go like this
i know that's what i need so that's why
i love curology because you could take a
short quiz right and you can go hey my
face is is is always greasy so i can
wash my face and get rid of the oil but
then they did send us their brand new
lip balm to keep my lips nice and
moisturized which is freaking awesome
and look at this guys the packaging is
pretty awesome yep look but the best
thing of all
is
this is like a switchblade yup
lip balm look at that it's so cool so
your days of opening the chopsticks the
whole thing melts off it's over they got
four new flavors vanilla original mint
and passion fruit and oh my god the
passion fruit one
smells so good
doesn't it smell like a cake
yes very very man i just want to suck on
it all day yeah it's freaking awesome so
curology makes ultra easy skin care
specifically for you they'll give you a
custom prescription that's created by a
dermatology provider because you take a
short online quiz and you can write what
your goals are like you got
greasy skin greasy skin dark skin
clogged pimples sunspots whatever
fine lines you want to get rid of those
things you put all of that in wrinkles
and then the dermatology provider will
give you a custom skin care
routine that's easy to follow and once
you follow it look both me and joe's
skin look way smoother and can you
believe it we're actually 52
yes
and when i smile my lips don't bleed
don't burst and bleed anymore because
they're nice and moisturized so you got
to give this a try like we did go to
curology.com off the record to get this
okay free 30-day trial a whole month
your face can change drastically in 30
days all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to curology.com
off the record that's
o-f-f-t-h-e-r-e-c-o-r-d to get this
special get 30 days for free
just pay five dollars for shipping and
you can cancel at any time go to
curology.com off the record if you had
to punch it like a [ __ ] celebrity in
the face who would it be park one um if
i had to punch a celebrity in the face
yeah dinner alive mgk
uh
covington
yeah
why because he does he was mean to
eminem
pretty good he even the conor mcgregor
[ __ ] it's like bro you're not that tough
chill oh
let someone punch you in the face and
see how tough you are you know okay he's
like he's like a pretty boy i think he's
a bad boy oh yeah but he's [ __ ]
making [ __ ] you gotta hand this he is
[ __ ] making [ __ ] you gotta handle
the guy a little bit right yeah would
you like to open it all right
would you just acknowledge these [ __ ]
megan blocks that's that's handing it to
him i guess
all right opposite then if you had to
like [ __ ] any celebrity who would it be
uh the uh what's your name uh
what's her name uh she plays hermione
celebrity crush
so emma watson yeah from the chamber of
secrets right
not from that movie
i knew what steve was trying to do it
[Music]
but he chose the movie when she was like
12. i don't know i don't even know that
bro
i mean you guys are like the same age
though right so during that time were
you beating off to [ __ ] harry potter
[ __ ] you're me no i wasn't actually he's
beating out to snape
that's what black people
that snake kind of looked like mine
so we've hit the 11 minute 26 second
mark the time of show where we like to
get deep and personal exact time that's
what we do everything's super [ __ ]
hot man so this is where the the the
seat gets real hot yeah um
you know are you still a virgin no uh
last when i was 18 18. damn did you cry
during it no but it did go by really
quick and i was like all right that's
over with dude you didn't cry after how
quick you feel so special so beautiful
honestly like low-key maybe like
three minutes
that's not that's pretty long
yeah first time is longer than my
normals yeah yes
three minutes that's i gotta be at least
20 pounds at least i take my time with
it you feel me he knows what i'm talking
about
i was i was a three pump chop dude do
you send flowers to the girl every year
on virgin idiot on virginity day nah and
she like
that girl now is currently like with
somebody and has a kid so that would be
a little so you guys never talk no we're
still cool
yeah the customer is you're supposed to
send flowers to the girl that you lost
your virginity to everybody like thank
you i don't think i would have ever been
foggy what day is virginia
every here it's coming up yeah it's
going up tomorrow and you send them
flowers and you go thank you because you
were my first yeah my last my everything
yeah yeah i still love you see joe's
done
[Laughter]
well you'll always love them they always
have a party right yeah
what's something that you are very a
proud of of your accomplishments
um
probably i mean just i guess where i'm
at today just from where i came from
when i moved here from arizona what i
was doing at the time then and then what
i'm doing now explain to the camera what
you do yeah he's in the [ __ ] hot tube
dude incredible i was uh well i just i
was deep into rap music so i was around
like a lot of
like drugs i used to hang out with a lot
of bloods and
just i got shot at twice uh two weeks
before i moved here in arizona so you're
like i'm gonna change my life yeah so i
moved here
i got shot by blood so now i'm gonna
join the crips because they don't get
shot at because i had beef with those
other guys
no but i moved around a week's notice
just my mom had moved out here so it was
kind of just like
maybe this isn't the best way to be
living life right now but there's still
bloods here
i know but i didn't hang around the
bloods here
can we get a hot seat wrap
so no i'm not good at freestyling
so so
that was one thing i never did was
freestyle
so
so when you came here
you're like
i'm gonna change my life
[ __ ] play video games bro like
when i first came here i was still doing
music a little bit but it like changed
because every day i had like a whole
group that i was making music with like
you know we had like six people every
day we were recording i had a little
recording studio so when i moved here it
was by myself and it kind of became like
not boring but like it was just you know
you usually have someone like feed off
of and make songs with and it kind of
just
became boring but then i started lifting
and it was powerlifting was that your
anti-gang anti-drug life yeah that
honestly though but it did like change
every like my whole entire life because
that led into me becoming a trainer uh
and yeah
that was like you were a coach like you
training people i was a personal trainer
and then like uh yeah coaching
powerlifting coach that's kind of how i
met him
uh and then i wasn't tender it was
tinder it was grinder actually but yeah
that's why because i saw that he was a
lifter on tinder so that matched and
then
but seriously so like the life of a
gamer is kind of interesting because you
your your your power lift like i assume
your schedule's like wake up grind kind
of thing like you you go lift and then
when do you get to the gaming part at
the end of the day and so like let's say
it's let's do it just a little snare
it's like midnight right and you're
getting tired and then you go check your
fridge and you're out of gaming fuel
are you like just completely [ __ ] or
like i just don't game at that point
yeah you don't get it yeah
yeah
yeah gamer feel dude that's body gas
what's your favorite gamer fuel that you
use uh i like to eat a banana and
make some coffee for the texture banana
cup i'm talking about the beverage dude
oh the drink yeah you get the gamer you
got the i just think water or like coke
zero this guy's not a real gamer
oh you're talking about g g-fuel
gamer yeah oh i've had it a couple times
this shit's way too strong though it's
like 300 milligrams of caffeine
and like you're sitting there playing
and then you're just like getting
cross-eyed and it's just too much
that much
the kid the asian kid that i saw beat
punch out without getting punched one
time he's [ __ ] on gamerfield just
[ __ ] locked in yeah but his heart
rate's probably like this
and then he's probably gonna like die in
like ten years from heart disease or
something do you have beef with anybody
in arizona where if you went back no i
actually don't i don't oh wow i'm very
happy so was it like squashed at all was
it like crossfire shooting where you're
just like they're just shooting at other
people that you're uh i should have
nothing to do with them [ __ ] i'm
trying to [ __ ] kill you [ __ ] one of
them had nothing to do with me but the
second one was kind of that well i was
recording at my friend dee's house and
we pulled up and then they're right
hello
he was with dean
and an a was in the corner david so nick
came through you know he started popping
off
so it was a drive-by uh sort of kinda
they were aiming at my friend he had
some beef with this other kid named i'll
say b
what's his real name b for b billy i
think honestly i think that kid's in
jail right now i think he like shot some
girl in the head or something like that
it was like some big thing out there and
is this in phoenix uh yeah i lived in
phoenix i went to school in iwatuki they
were from phoenix
and then what was bad about that was
that everybody from like south phoenix
like maricopa i would had a lot of like
open open campus schools so anybody was
able to go there so it was like a really
nice town and like kind of rich but it
was just a bunch of bad people going in
it interesting
open campus does that mean like no
district you could just sort yeah there
was like one i know there was one high
school called desert vista that was
close campus you have to live like 10
miles away at least or maximum 10 miles
away from the school you can go like
where i went mountain point you could
live wherever like you live an hour away
and go to it and
uh so yeah just kind of let
anybody go there so like i said you had
a lot of people from like where i grew
up in south phoenix and then maricopa
county and
just all the
do you feel like l.a saved you
yeah i think so like you you would have
been like living the hard life like
sucking some jail dick right now to
survive i definitely wouldn't be doing
that you know you probably be getting
your dick sucked in yet yeah
i think it did i mean like towards the
end it would start again to the point
where it was like i was starting to
become like really broke a lot of my
friends used to go car hopping and like
that was a thing hopping you basically
just walk around and check door handles
and if one's open you open it take
everything out uh so they were doing
that a lot i was trying not to because i
was working like a best buy so i had
like a good job you were one of the good
ones yeah and uh i was the guy that had
the studio so like i was recording
everybody and then but it just got to
that point where i was just like all
right i think i'm gonna start going and
you never pulled any of the best buy
scams no they'll catch you yeah what do
they do right now if you worry about
best mattresses
back in the day there was a bunch of
rackets where like guys would uh they
would you would like get a tv from one
of the employees and they would like
mark it as something they had to open
yeah yeah yeah and then you just keep it
and then but then you could return it
but you'd still have it that's
absolutely sick yeah yeah but they
should crack they crack down on that
like yeah everybody if you cat best buy
is a a big company and usually if you're
stealing from there you get caught just
a matter of time i've seen so much just
get a tv open the box walk up to the
front and say can i return this and
they're like you got a receipt and he
goes no and he's like no you can't and
he goes okay and he walks out
oh [ __ ]
i like walking into it with the tv out
and like the cords like dragging on the
ground and [ __ ] what is [ __ ] what a
legend okay
just [ __ ] go to the tv i'll rip the
box open walk up to the front and say i
would like to return this wait does he
walk out with the tv though now he's a
tv yeah yeah that's amazing and they're
like well if you don't have the receipt
we can't [ __ ] return this i thought
he was like god damn it i have his
[ __ ] tv
i definitely miss that
alex when's the last time you cried
uh probably like two days ago cool oh
[ __ ] what was involved it was about you
know you had no idea i just i get little
like depression or like stress or
anxiety start [ __ ] tearing up bro
right yeah i'll just walk put on some
depressing music and start crying
something you just get out and then
you're good did you say when you walk
like you're walking down the street and
just start crying yeah like it was uh
yesterday was like or two days ago it's
like 11 p.m went for a
walk that is the saddest show what was
the song you put on what was the music
you put on uh actually that day i was
listening to him some exciting stuff i
was listening like system of it down
hey cool but my one of my clients had a
heart attack recently so i was like
thinking about that and i was like all
right let me cry now so then like when
it happens i'm like i'm good you know
hey man honestly sometimes you need to
cry to just get it out feel better you
know what's the last thing you cry
i'm not in the hot seat
and this has been pulling focus
he did it again you know
you